Today I'll be presenting about big data, big
brain data science and predictive health analytics.
So to begin with, I
want to show you a brief outline of what I
would be covering the next 40 to 45 minutes
today.
First of all, I will start
off with discussing some driving biomedical
and health challenges that lead to some of
the necessary
developments in the data science world, in
the computational statistics world.
So then I will focus on identifying some of
the common characteristics that often times
describe big brain data.
I
will explicitly define what I mean by data
science and predictive analytics.
And I will go over several case studies,
specifically in the domain of neurodegenerative
disorders.
I'll show you one coapplication of data dashboarding,
using the software dashboard web app.
And then finally, I'll present to you the
idea behind a really interesting new methodological
development,
something called compressive big data analytics,
that is intended to provide a canonical way
of mathematically
representing, statistically analyzing, and
computationally processing large complex heterogeneous
data sets.
So that's the outline.
So let's start off with some examples of driving
biomedical and health challenges.
So this is a
recent study that we did a year and a half,
two years ago, looking at Alzheimer's disease,
specifically as a
component of the vast spectrum of neurodegenerative
disorders.
So in that specific study, we had about 800
Alzheimer's disease subjects coming from the
Alzheimer's disease neuroimaging initiative,
a large public-private
initiative to aggregate a very heterogeneous
multi-source, multi-institutional collection
of data for patients,
Alzheimer's disease patients, as well as asymptomatic
controls in these individuals that are kind
of transitioning
from being controls into being patients.
Something called MCI, so mildly cognitively
impaired individuals.
So in this specific study, we looked at the
three different cohorts, and what we did is
we extracted about 80, what
we called derived neuroimaging biomarkers.
And then additional 80 associated SNPs that
were highly associated
with the diagnoses.
In this case, controls, MCIs, and ADs, in
that kind of progressive spectrum.
So the images on
the left here illustrate some of the parcelations
that we did for the brain, and some of the
statistics that we extract,
and you can find more about that study in
that publication.
So there is the recognition that when you
analyze biomedical health data, there is typically
three facets of
variability that one needs to be aware.
The first one is obviously the phenotype,
which is the outward
manifestation of the form, shape, size, characterization,
of the specific individual, if you're doing
precision
medicine on an individual level.
Or cohort-based science, atlas-based studies
and population-based studies.
Or
you can be doing phenotyping based on various
comorbid conditions.
In addition to the phenotype, we have
obviously the nature, or the genome, that
plays role in everything that we look at,
in biomedical world.
And then
there is also the nurture and the environment.
Now, across these three pillars, I guess,
of natural studies, chance plays a big role.
So there is random effects,
there is noise that needs to be deal with.
And one of the-- on the right side here, I
tried to indicate this notion that
most of the studies effectively resolve into
trying to tease out effective biological signal,
relative to their natural
presence of biological noise, as well as noise
that's technically introduced by the equipment,
by humans, by the
processing, et cetera.
So most of the studies that people do effectively
revolve around trying to maximize the information
content, or
signal, relative to the corresponding noise
that is unavoidable to a large extent.
So in this next slide, I'm trying to
make the case for why should we look at big
data?
And what is big data?
And what is standard data, or classical,
or small data.
So in this left panel here, I have a representation
of a natural process here.
So the native process
could be something that's inscribing in this
specific case, go blue here, with different
type of characteristics for
these individuals colors, orientations of
the subjects, and so forth.
And on the extreme, on the right-hand side,
you have typical what a sample data set represents.
It's a snapshot
that's pretending to be a proxy of the actual
population, which oftentimes is not completely
observable through a
census.
So most of the time, we view these limited
process snapshots of the observations and
we try to make the
inference using data on the bottom right corner
to infer the scripture that's on the bottom
left corner.
Now big data is this in-between case, where
you're collecting, obviously not a census
of the population, but you're
collecting sufficient amount of large-scale
information about the process, looking at
different directions, different
scale, different modalities, et cetera.
And you're trying to, again, do the same thing.
You're trying to infer
characterization of computable phenotypes
on the actual native process, which is often
times not observable in its
entirety.
So obviously there's pros and cons for looking
at sample-based inference statistics, versus
looking at big data
inference, where there's lots of challenges,
in terms of the harmonization, the aggregation,
the processing, et
cetera.
So by the way, my colleague, Crystal, she
is going to be reviewing.
If anybody has any questions, you can
post them in a chat and towards the end, we'll
probably have a chance to go over some questions
or comments
that may arise during the presentation.
So in this next slide, I'm showing you what
we call the constructive definition of big
biomedical data.
So big data
obviously was first defined by IBM, in terms
of the four Vs, about a decade ago.
They recognized that the volume,
the variety, the speed at which data changes,
and the veracity, are important characteristics
and they call these
4Vs.
Now these four Vs are nowadays extended to
seven Vs and eight Vs. There is more v-words
that describe
the complexities that have to do with big
data.
Now last year, what we did is we tried to
come up with a more structured, constructive
definition that identifies very
specifically what are the challenges and what
are the needs for tools, software, and services
that are very specific
to these what we call big biomedical data,
big brain data, et cetera.
So the size is obviously one of these
characteristics.
It's one of the paramount characteristics,
but we don't stop there.
There is complexities with the data that requires
special type of data handlers, wranglers,
that allow us to
manipulate heterogeneous data elements.
Then you have data incongruency.
The data will not be homologous
between subjects, between sites that are acquiring
the data, and so forth.
So sampling rates, so there's a lot of
tools that are necessary and techniques to
deal with this incongruency.
Another very important characteristic of big
data is that it often times arrives from multiple
sources.
So the
transfer, the joint modeling and processing
of these disparate elements is a huge barrier
currently.
then you can
be looking at the same process, the same phenomenon.
For example, the human brain, at multiple
scales.
Starting on the top, at the macroscopic level,
you have typically resolution of the brain
at about 1 millimeter.
And
then you can go down to cryotomographic data,
where you can have microscopic, or mesoscale.
And it you can go down to the nanoscale, or
a single channel recordings, where you are
on the micron level.
So
you're looking at exactly the same substrate,
exactly the same process, but you're looking
at different resolutions.
So the multi-scale aspect of big brain data
is very important.
And last, but certainly not least, is the
fact that big
data is always, always incomplete.
So mechanisms of dealing with that incompleteness,
our group and other groups are developing
batch mode
techniques.
Because often times, if you have, as soon
as you cross the 10 to 100,000 cases, you
cannot-- it's
simply computationally impractical with current
technology, to do holistic, what's called
imputation.
To obtain
complete snapshots of the data that can be
processed using more traditional techniques.
So let's go ahead and define specifically
what we mean by data science and predictive
analytics, because these
terms are important.
So in my world, data science is defined as
this emerging, extremely transdisciplinary
area,
which bridges the theoretical, the computational,
the experimental, and then the biosocial or
the biomedical areas.
Data science deals with these characteristics
that I defined earlier, these enormous amounts
of complex
incongruent, heterogeneous dynamically changing
data that arise from multiple streams or multiple
sources.
Data science always develops methods, tests
methods, validates methods, shares methods,
tools, services, and
capabilities, to enable ingestion of these
complex data sets, and applying completely
automated or semiautomated
decision support methods and systems.
Predictive analytics is the process that we
use for utilizing
advanced mathematical formalizations, powerful
statistical algorithms, and efficient software
tools-- as well as
services-- to number one, represent, number
two, interrogate, and number three, interpret,
complex data sets.
So
predictive analytics focuses on identifying
trends, clusters, motifs, prognostication
of process behaviors, either
across time, space, within the range and outside
of the range of the originally observed data.
And again, I want to remind you of the little
cartoon that I had early on, about the complete
population data, the go
blue schematic versus the big data set and
the small samples of traditional samples.
Because this notion of
observing data outside of range and inside
of the range is very important so, by the
way, these two definitions
come up from on-- they are directly coming
from an upcoming Springer book on the topic
of data science and
predictive analytics.
So this is a diagram that illustrates a typical
process when you are analyzing big brain data.
The typical process
starts with collecting the data that comes
as raw observations, bits, bytes, that are
typically aggregated.
You have
data scrubbing, data cleaning, manipulations,
and so forth, that need to be conducted first,
before some kind of an
information gets extracted out of these data.
For instance, summary statistics.
In our case, we take the raw imaging, magnetic
resonance imaging scans, for example.
And then we remove the
non-brain tissue.
Then we model the cortical surface of the
brain, which is the boundary between the gray
matter
and the cerebrospinal fluid, using mathematical
two-dimensional manifolds.
So that's in the information content.
And then the next step, the next column here
is the knowledge generation phase, at which
you begin to look at
these models, and you obtain summary statistics.
For example, you can be computing surface
areas, you can be
computing shape indices, you can be computing
fractal dimension, you can be computing a
variety of
morphometry measures for each of these areas.
And then, based on these, you typically develop
learning
algorithms, or classifiers, that can lead
to some action that obviously, is in our world,
pertains to mediating normal
development or various heterogeneous brain
disorders.
So I want to start with some examples now,
or case studies.
So in the first case study, this is a case
study of
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis.
A very debilitating, progressive neurodegenerative
disorders.
So we wanted to
identify predictive mechanisms to detect,
track, and prognosticate the progression of
ALS across time.
Now
although ALS is not extremely common-- there
is about 30,000 to 50,000 cases in the US--
it is very debilitating.
It's also called Lou Gehrig's disease, and
Stephen Hawking is one of those prominent,
outspoken obviously
patients with ALS.
So in this specific case, we had a very heterogeneous
data set.
That started again, over 100 different features
were recorded, for a number of subjects.
They included demographic data, clinical data,
what are called ALSFRS,
these amyotrophic lateral sclerosis functional
rating scale clinical measures.
There were, in addition, adverse
events included with some of the patients.
And we started with about 8,600 cases.
And in the process of stratifying
the data and manipulating the data to the
point where it becomes a single computable
object that can be jointly
monitored and interrogated, the data was reduced
to about 2,400 cases, simply to avoid missingness,
to avoid
incongruencies, and so forth.
And then we looked in this specific case,
trying to predict the progression of the disease,
in terms of monitoring
these ALSFRS metrics, very specifically finding
the slope.
So we are given the information at baseline,
zero
month, and then at month three, one quarter
later.
We're given this information and we are asked
to predict a 12-
month follow up.
Where is the ALSFRS clinical score for these
patients going to be?
So we developed this fairly
elaborate protocol that's shown in the left,
that illustrates very concretely, how we go
from the original
observations, all the way down to the predictions
and then the assessment of these predictions,
in terms of
various quantitative evaluation metrics.
The panel on the left shows you the variable
importance plot, that directly identifies
features that are important in
that prediction of the 12-month follow up
from the first three months of observations.
And then the table on the
bottom right illustrates three different types
of classifiers, linear, model-based techniques
and then three modelfree
machine learning based techniques, using random
forest, based in adaptive regression trees,
and a
superlative method.
And then the rows in the table illustrate
three very specific metrics that quantify
the
performance.
One is called the R-squared metric, that identifies
the relative model performance.
The root means square error.
And then the correlation between the actual
observed ALSFRS slope change between the first
three months and
the 12-month, and the actual predicted, by
the corresponding method slope change.
And you can see that we're
reaching about 0.5 or so prediction accuracy.
The second neurodegenerative study that I
want to point out is a Parkinson's disease
study.
So there is something
very similar for Parkinson's as there is for
ALS.
There is clinical scores called uniform Parkinson's
disease rating
scale assessments.
And again, we are trying to predict the progression
of the clinical diagnosis of the patients.
Can we separate, for instance, patients from
age match controls?
With and without using the corresponding
UPDRS clinical assessments that the physicians
base their diagnoses on?
So the table on the bottom illustrates, again,
a little bit about the cohort.
There is genetics data, there is imaging
data, there is three different cohorts.
Asymptomatic controls or their controls, the
patients, the PD patients, and
then there is these patients that are in between
they're called SWEDDs, subjects without evidence
of
dopaminergic deficit.
So if you look at their imaging scans, the
radiologist can not clearly identify a Parkinson's
disease deficit, in terms of dopamine change.
So for that specific study we again, developed
an end-to-end protocol that starts with the
data aggregation on the
So for that specific study we again, developed
an end-to-end protocol that starts with the
data aggregation on the
very left.
It goes through the data harmonization, aggregation
of all these different modalities of the data
coming
from the multiple sources.
They're very incongruent, they cannot not
be represented in the same function or
bases.
Then we did the cleaning, the imputation,
the wrangling of the data.
And then because the cohorts, in the previous
slide, it was shown that the sizes of the
three different cohorts that we are studying
are not very balanced.
So for
example, the patients outnumbered controls
three to one.
There's a potential bias that may be introduced
by the
patient cohort.
So we used synthetic minority oversampling
method, which is a statistical technique that
allow us to rebalance--
approximately, not exactly, but approximately--
the sample size of the three cohorts.
So that we avoid potential
bias.
And then we did both, just like in the ALS
world, we did both model-based, for example,
linear model and
model-free classification of all the patients.
And then we did predictions and we validated
the results.
The workflow diagram that's in the bottom
left corner here, shows you the end-to-end
protocol, the data goes
essentially over 80 to 90 different processing
steps to go from its raw aggregated state,
into some of these cortical
surface maps and parcelated maps.
And statistical signature vectors is what
we call these numbers that drive the
actual classification at the end.
And on the right hand side you have, again,
a variable importance plot, that
illustrates which feature, and you can see
here, there is demographic features, like
age.
There's imaging features,
like the left superior occipital gyrus surface
area is one of these features.
You have clinical measures, the UPDRS part
one was highly predictive of the diagnostic
outcome of the subjects,
et cetera.
And you can see in the bottom right table,
again, some stunning statistics.
And these are certainly not
surprising, adaptive boosting and support
vector machine classifiers.
We're able to discriminate between the
different diagnostic cohorts incredibly well.
Now this was simply because we use the actual
UPDRS, the uniform
Parkinson's disease rating scale measures,
which the physicians themselves use in the
determination of a
diagnosis.
When we exclude these clinical UPDRS biomarkers,
our classification goes down to about 80%,
which is a
substantial decrease.
However, it is still pretty impactful and
a reliable indication that machine learning
methods
can be used to do fairly powerful predictive
analytics.
So in this specific case study, just to summarize,
we have
developed an end-to-end big brain data analytical
protocol that can jointly model, represent,
and interrogate
imaging, genetic, clinical, and demographic
data, to assess the risk for Parkinson's disease.
The source code is
available on this GitHub site, under the predictive
big data analytics software project.
Now let me follow up with something very recent.
So this is hot off the presses, they say,
although it's not peer
reviewed.
It is a very, very interesting new study,
looking at Parkinson's disease patients falls.
Can you predict
physical injury from falling in Parkinson's
disease?
So in Parkinson's disease there is two clinical
phenotypes.
There is tremor dominance, with people that
have limbs that basically shake and the second
type is called gait
instability and posture instability, or posture
instability and gait disorder.
So these are freezing of gait and various
other disorders.
So in this specific case, we were interested
in doing three very specific challenges.
The first one is, we had data
from two different sources, here at the University
of Michigan, we have a Udall Center for Excellence
in
Parkinson's Disease.
A U50 grant, funded by the National Institute
of Health, where we are collecting a lot of
data
on Parkinson's patients.
And a colleague of ours at Tel Aviv University
collected, completely independently, a very
similar data set, again studying the same
cohort, not the same individuals, the same
cohort, of PD subjects.
So the first challenge in this study was to
try to harmonize and aggregate these multi-source
and complex data
set.
The second challenge was to identify what
are the clinically relevant features that
are associated with very
specific clinical traits?
For example, falls.
And the third one is trying to predict now,
once you have the feature
selection, can you predict falls in these
Parkinson's disease using, again, model-based
or model-free machine
learning methods?
So the study design is illustrated in this
diagram.
First of all, we did this independently, study
the Udall University of Michigan data set.
We did the feature selection,
we did the modeling, we did what's called
statistical internal cross-validation of the
results.
And we did this
independently for the two data sets, the Tel
Aviv University data set and Udall.
Then in the second phase, we
actually aggregated the two data set and then
we did the modeling and the cross validation
on the aggregate data
set, as well as we did an external out-of-bag
training on one of the data sets.
And testing, or assessment, on the
other.
So the results were fairly encouraging.
We have, as I mentioned, missing data is one
of these key challenges that
characterizes big biomedical data and big
brain data, in specific.
So this diagram on the chart on the left corner
here, shows you the missing pattern of the
data.
And on the right, on the top right, I can
show you some of the
differences in various, in four clinically
relevant variables, like tremor score, or
posture instability and gait disorder
score, and various other metrics, between
the fallers and the non-fallers, indicated
with purple and yellow colors.
And then, one of the big challenges that occurred
in this case study, which is certainly very
common when you do
big biomedical data, is the fact that the
data will not be congruent or the statistically
aggregatable.
So the diagram
that you see, the histogram plot on the bottom
left corner, illustrates the very substantial
amount of difference
between the distributions of various features
between the Michigan and the Tel-Aviv data.
So everything that exceeds that threshold,
that red curve, that I hope is visible here,
the horizontal red curve, that
is inverse log scale of the statistical significance
on the Kolmogorov-Smirnov test, between different
features.
And
you can see about half the features are not
statistically distinct between the two populations,
but a huge number
of features are very, very distinct between
the two university databases.
So how can this be explained?
How can
these be handled to allow us to literally
aggregate and learn from a bigger data set?
OK, so we move forward, we dealt with these
challenges, and I just want to show you some
of the results.
So we
did the feature selection, by two different,
very interesting methods.
One is called a random forest feature
selection.
And you can see, in the middle column here,
the feature name, the variable names.
And then right next to it, the frequency of
how frequently, and how common was it, how
important was it, in the
prediction of the clinically relevant outcome?
In this case, falling or not-falling.
And then knockoff filter, in the
second column in this table on the right,
illustrates a controlled variable selection,
where you have a mechanism of
controlling the false positive rate of selecting
these features.
And you can see that seven of these features
are commonly chosen by the two completely
independent
strategies.
So that's a very strong indicator that we
might have zeroed down on which observations,
which data
elements, would be highly predictive or associated
with falls in Parkinson's.
The bottom right table that's shown
here in the corner, illustrates a variety
of metrics from model-based logistic regression
of identifying and fallers
from non-fallers, to random forest, adaptive
boosting, HG boosting, a number of alternative
machine learning
based methods.
And you can see that one of the best classifier,
in this case, random forest achieves accuracy
of about 80%, with a
fairly high specificity of about 0.87.
And sensitivity, not as good, but about 0.7.
So this is, again, fairly encouraging.
Now once you have that you can, obviously,
make recommendations to physicians, families,
caregivers, and so
forth, about what to watch for or what to
look at.
Now in this next case study, we looked at
a more generic population, almost looking
at a census.
So this data
comes from the United Kingdom, this is the
UK Biobank.
In this specific case study, we wanted to
discriminate
between healthy patients and multiple comorbid--
patients with multiple comorbid conditions.
Now in the UK
Biobank data, what is interesting is that
they try to take a snapshot of the entire
population, in this case.
And this
shows a little bit about the data.
So over half a million cases, over 4,000 features.
They do include imaging data,
not for all the subjects, but for many subjects,
about 10,000 subjects, they have structural
and functional imaging
and diffusion imaging data.
They have genetics data and so forth.
So it was a very challenging study.
And the URL links that are provided here,
in the bottom right corner might be
useful, if you want to follow up with this.
This is all public data, you can request data.
So just to show some of the
complexities here, right, so we looked at
the features, these literally 4,100 features.
And we only looked at the
complexities here, right, so we looked at
the features, these literally 4,100 features.
And we only looked at the
ones that are highly observed.
So more than 30% of the cases having observed
data.
And this is just a plot to
illustrate the missingness rate.
So it turns out that in our situation, we
essentially wanted to zero down on the subjects
that had imaging data,
because we know really well how to do computational
neuroscience.
We know how to obtain these derived
neuroimaging signature factors.
So for these 10,000 subjects, as you can see,
9,900 or so cases, we looked at
the highly observed clinical phenotypes about
these 1,500 or so features.
And we wanted to examine what is the
missing pattern?
What features are missing?
What is the rate of missing?
And as you can see here, there is a very high
rate of missingness.
So we needed to develop techniques to deal
with that missingness.
The missingness is obviously not random, you
can see from that pattern.
So innovative
statistical methods are required to be able
to preprocess these specific data set to the
point where it can become,
again, a computable data object, that we can
interrogate, either with or without model-based
techniques.
So a little bit about the protocol.
So we developed this pipeline workflow, that
shows on a very high level here, the
process is that the imaging data goes through
from volume preprocessing to parcelation to
computational, the
morphometry measures, all the way up to the
result aggregation into these spreadsheets
or computable data
objects.
So not everything-- when you do computing
on this kind of scale, not everything is going
to be perfect.
You're
going to have some successes and some failures.
So I'm just showing you here, that when you
do a computing on
this scale, things are not always going to
be right.
So in this specific case, we have 99% of the--
it says, 8,348
compute jobs were done, at this specific phase
of the pipeline workflow. 99% of them are
complete.
One was
canceled and 469 instances of the calculations
failed.
So we can track down, it is very important,
through the LONI pipeline environment, to
be able to track precisely
what steps in what cases fail, so that you
can remedy and examine if there is anything
common for them.
Now
obviously, your inference needs to be based
on the complete cases, going forward.
A little bit about the pipeline work environment
that we've been developing at LONI, and at
the INI at USC, this has
been a project that, again, has started as
is being funded as a P41 project, part of
the National Institute of Health.
It allows users to design, on their client
machine, these complicated protocols, so that
the calculations can be
outsourced to an external pipeline distributed
server, where the calculations can be parallelized
on complex
computational platforms.
So the user doesn't have to worry about managing
of the data node assignments, job
tracking, aggregation of results, and so forth.
This is all kind of managed by the distributed
pipeline server on the background.
The user only worries about the
front-end design of the actual scientific
protocol, the algorithm, the pipeline workflow.
That's what we do, and then
our colleagues at IT and the pipeline team
actually worry about all the back-end things
that are, indeed, very
important, for these types of calculations.
So this is a slide that shows you a tool that
we developed as part of the Big Data Discovery
Science, BD2K center.
A couple of years ago, it's called the Big
Data Dashboard.
It allows you to essentially query databases,
multivariate
multi-source databases, without writing a
single line of SQL or any database language
code, to essentially
visually generate a collage of images, each
image representing one or multiple variables.
And then all of these
charts are interactive, so they are like trellis
charts.
You can narrow the scope of the states, or
for example, you can select states, or you
can select, in this case, this
is the histogram of the average commute time
for these individuals.
So you can manipulate any one of these
charts, and as you manipulate one of them,
all the other charts morph to reflect the
subsetting, to reflect the
stratification that the user introduces in
one or several of these charts.
So during that interactive, visual-based
data interrogation, you are able to formulate
interesting research hypotheses about what
might be the multivariate
intricate relations that are not a priori
known.
So we can generate hypotheses that can obviously
be tested
through rigorous computational mechanisms.
So in this example that I just show you, we
used data from the Center for Medicare Services,
the CMS, on the
Medicare services.
We used data from the US Census Bureau and
the Bureau of Labor Statistics, just to illustrate
how data can be pulled from multiple incongruent,
in this case federal databases, but they're
not designed to
necessarily interoperate.
So we will demonstrate how the data can be
aggregated and therefore interrogated real
time, through visual analytic concepts.
All right, so in the last few minutes, I just
want to tell you about this compressive big
data analytics strategy that
our group is developing.
So a little bit of motivation here, there
is no current mathematical foundation of how
to
analyze big data.
The science, the big data science is not developed.
So we have looked at, again, the big data
characteristics, and we have introduced this
strategy that allows us to do a stochastic-based
inference
independent of the very specific case-based
data characteristics.
As long as the data has the six dimensions
that I
showed in one of my earlier slides, a large
size, coming from multiple sources, incongruency,
multi-scale,
incomplete, and so forth.
We are developing this iterative, statistical
stochastic algorithm that will allow us to
generically process that data in
such a way that we generate subsamples from
the big data, then we use model-based or model-free
techniques
to analyze these samples, compute various
likelihoods, estimates, relations, or qualitative
or quantitative relations
between variables.
We repeat this process multiple times, and
we effectively look at the asymptotics.
We look at
the ergodic properties of these algorithms.
So this diagram illustrates a little bit of
process.
It's a eight-step process, very, very generic.
It doesn't deal with
brain data, it doesn't deal with neurodegenerative
data.
It deals with any data set that has the six
dimensions that I
outlined earlier about big biomedical data
sets.
So the first step is obviously the pre-processing
cleaning step.
Eliminating very strong dependencies, recasting
data type point necessary, dealing with missingness,
and so
forth.
In step two, it does the data harmonization,
the data set-- just like in the Udall Michigan
versus Tel Aviv
Parkinson's disease falls data set that I
showed you, there has to be a data aggregation
in harmonization step.
In the second step, we do the variable selection
and so forth.
And then we go through the iterative CBDA,
the
compressive big data analytics iterative protocol,
where we randomly sample, in step four, a
decent set.
Then we
do the imputation, scaling, rebalancing, which
I mentioned earlier as well, when we did the
Parkinson's disease
study.
Then we do the knockoff controlled variable
selection, or perhaps other variable selection,
it doesn't have to
be knockoff.
And we apply multiple machine learning methods,
like the SuperLearner.
Then we go ahead and rank mean square root
errors or accuracy metrics to identify how
consistent are our
results, across different iterations.
And then in the final step, we do the feature
mining that allows us to identify
these variables that are highly-- that appear
frequently, across the multiple random walks
through the cloud of
data.
So it is a very interesting algorithm, we
are right now in the process of validating
it.
So more on that later.
But I want to point out some very important
things for us as a community, to look at the
FAIR data and open
science principles.
So FAIR refers to findable, A refers to accessible,
the I refers to interoperable, and R refers
to
reusable data set.
So as we all collect, manage, process, and
understand a complex data set we should always
keep these four in mind, and I'm sure many
of us do.
This is very important.
And the open science aspects, again, not only
for the publications, but my group, the
SOCR group, is actually using open continuous
development.
All of these things that I'm showing to you,
the
CBDA method, it's already on GitHub, even
before it's being published, sharing the data.
All the data, the code,
and the science is being shared at the time
of development.
It's not shared after post hoc.
It is shared during the
process of development.
So this obviously entices new investigators
to contribute, share, collaborate, extend,
and so forth.
So this final
example, I know we are approaching 12:50 here
on the East Coast, and 9:50 on the West Coast,
here in the US.
So the last thing I just want to show is an
area very interesting data set.
Now in this case, about 60,000 patients,
and we looked at hospital admissions.
The data is not very feature rich in this
case, only nine features are
recorded, including admission, the length
of the admission, a binary indicator variable
of whether the patient
survived, et cetera, and some demographics.
We used very similar predictors trying to
identify, for instance, can we figure out
who, at the time of admission, is
likely to die.
So this confusion matrix that you have in
the bottom right here-- on the bottom left
corner, illustrates
that the survivals are 9,900.
It identifies the patients that-- the algorithm,
in this case, random forest, classified as
patients that are expected to die, versus
how many did die.
So we have this confusion matrix, and you
can see
that we have a fairly decent internal cross-validation
accuracy of about 85%.
The sensitivity is very high, about 93%.
The specificity, however, is low, only 13%,
which indicates that we have a
very, very low rate of falsely positively
identifying individual as expected die when
they survived, but we might
have a fairly large rate of false negative
identification.
So people that did die, we might have missed
them.
On the bottom right corner, we use this algorithm
to, on a completely independent data set of
11,000 to 12,000
subjects, to essentially predict the probability
of survival.
What is that probability?
We're not interested in binary
classifying individuals as surviving, we just
want to have a likelihood which would help
physicians, clinicians and
the caregivers.
In addition-- so this is completely automated
decision support system that adds up another
level of
quantitative description about likelihood
of survival or not.
So just to give you, again, coming back to
the National Health Service in the UK, we
have begun the very same
exploratory data analytics using machine learning
methods on all of their data.
We are developing these
workflows, we're looking at their genotypes.
And ultimately, we're trying to design these
connectograms, that
shows us, on the left, on the left hemisphere
here, you have some brain regions or clinical
phenotypes.
On the
right hemisphere, you had some of these genomic
biomarkers, for instance.
So finally, in the interest of time, I'm going
to skip this very interesting traumatic brain
injury study, because I do
want to leave a few moments for questions.
And the secret sauce of success are three
things, right.
You have to
have the funding agencies, you have to have
the collaborators, and you have to have the
infrastructure to do that
type of study.
So right up here, you have again, a recognition
of the funding agencies, as well as the
corresponding grant IDs.
Students, fellow, coworkers are very important
in this research.
Big brain data and predictive health analytics
is a
very transdisciplinary area.
No one can do this individually, or even in
one lab.
You have to have colleagues from
multiple disciplines from multiple institutions
to do this kind of research.
And of course, you have to have the
infrastructure, because without the computing
resources, without the storage, without the
expertise, much of this
research is going to be very difficult.
So thank you very much.
I'll be more than happy to address questions
now.
Thank you so much, Ivo, that was an outstanding
tour of all these big data analytic projects
that you've had going
on.
One of the things which strikes me-- but before
I ask my question, I want to invite members
of our audience, if
you have any questions, please, use the little
GoToWebinar question submission system, which
is in that panel
that's probably on the right side of your
screen, to type in your question and we'll
get those.
Text it in and then we
can ask those of Dr. Dinov.
Ivo, how important is quality control, or
some level of quality assurance, of these
variety of data sets that you're
pulling from?
In particular was struck with all the different
publicly available governmental databases
that you're
pulling from.
Do you go through any quality assessment level
assessment of that data, to go and make sure
that
it's valid and make some sense.
And how do you look for outliers and that
sort of thing?
Yeah, that's a very good question and a very
common question, Jack.
And I'll tell you, for the dashboard example
that I illustrated with the CMS, Bureau of
Labor Statistics, and the Census Bureau, we
did go through a very
manual labor-intensive quality control.
For instance, just to give you an example,
there were millions of records.
And the federal government databases are full
of mistakes.
About 3% to 5% of the data was wrong.
We were able to correct about 2% to 3% of
them, simply by crossvalidating,
for example, things like FIPS codes and zip
codes and locale and what else.
So there is mechanisms
that you can do, well, I don't know, semi-intelligent
quality control.
So that's on one level, right.
So there are
mechanisms and you can do this.
On a larger scale, however, this process is
not practical.
And there is a danger, there is a danger that
if you collect
the big data set, it could represent a very
substantially biased or non-representative
data.
That's always going to
be the case.
Now the hope is that as we, collectively,
as community, improve the data quality, there
will be
mistakes, but these mistakes on average, over
the distribution of the data, they're going
to be representative of
the population.
So my personal approach is that we try to
do quality control the best we can, as long
as it doesn't overwhelm us,
initially.
And secondarily, we are hoping and we are,
to some extent, validating whether or not
the data is
representative of the census.
And that's a difficult challenge, without
a doubt.
So we have a question from one of our audience.
And I was particularly interested, too, is
you were going to
discuss how you used predictive analytics
in traumatic brain injury patients.
And I was hoping to see a little more
description of that, before you skipped through
it.
And looks like somebody else from our audience
was, too.
Can
you take a second, to just summarize that
for us?
Right, absolutely.
So let me talk over this a little bit.
And there will be a video, I hope, that plays
right.
So traumatic
brain injury is incredibly interesting and
incredibly challenging.
The basic challenge is the heterogeneity of
the
morbid condition, right.
Everybody can imagine that every single traumatic
brain injury is different.
So in this video here, we're illustrating
how we collected data from multiple sources,
for multiple individuals.
We
have access to the infrastructure, the pipeline
computing server that you see, and the pipeline
graphical workflow
environment.
And now what we try to do, is we literally
individually process every single subject.
So we parcelated
the brains, we looked at the morphometry metrics
that we can automatically compute, for every
region, for every
subject.
We're able to reconstruct their cortical surfaces.
And not only that, often times-- the injury
is very important, right.
Is the injury the gray matter?
Is it affecting in the myelinated white matter
tracts?
How severe is it?
Quantifying
some of these things, as well as the visual
representation are very important.
And TBI needs to be done on an
individual case.
So look what's happening with this specific--
as this image is going to shift now a little
bit, you can see that the
injury of this patient was in the inferior
temporal lobe.
Can everybody see the huge gap that we have,
the cavity
that's indicative of exactly where the injury
is.
How large is it?
How complex is it?
So these things are very
important.
And then we try to look in this specific case,
we try to see if that type of injury, was
a gunshot, motor
vehicle, or a bicycle accident?
And unfortunately, we only have about 40 to
50 cases, in this case.
We were trying to identify specific
commonalities.
We did not have enough power to identify anything
critical, but the process that we went through
was very powerful because we have built the
protocol.
We know how to analyze these cases, we just
need
additional, obviously, data and more processing
power to be able to obtain these on a larger
scale, because
without hundreds to thousands of cases, the
heterogeneity of TBI is really limiting the
scope of any method--
model-based or model-free, to yield anything
substantially interesting.
That's interesting.
Ivo, we have a question from one of our audience,
asking about that in the big data era, this
era
of gathering ever more larger data sets, one
of the first things people seem to be interested
in doing is applying
machine learning techniques, in order to be
able to make predictions about classifying
subjects or being able to
make predictions about what something might
be or whatnot.
But the alternative is, can we make inferences?
And how do we make inferences, even though
we can make
these algorithms which do prediction?
And is there a distinction?
And how can we identify features or the relative
importance of some variables versus others?
And that you're uniquely qualified to comment
on this, so I'd throw
this back to you.
Right, so that's a very interesting point.
I want to start off by saying that data science
is recognized effectively, by
many of us, as the fourth scientific pillar,
in addition to the experimental sciences is
that started during, well, during
the Renaissance era, to the theoretical sciences
that started in the 17th, 18th, and 19th century.
The
computational sciences, which effectively
matured in the 20th century, and in the 21st
century we have the data
sciences.
It is true that you can-- scientific discovery
can be hypothesis driven or exploratory.
So this can be called
exploratory versus confirmatory science.
Machine learning methods can be used for both.
You can use machine
learning methods to formulate a research testable
hypothesis that can be prospectively tested
or validated using
other methods.
But it can be used for inference as well,
simply because the statisticians in the past
decade have
realized very interesting phenomenon, OK.
Hypothesis-based inference is rooted in the
notion that you quantify uncertainty in terms
of P-values.
Data science
inference is rooted in the understanding that
the probability values that you compute here
are replaced , by or
augmented by, looking at quality metrics like
the log odds ratio, like the positive and
negative predictive power, like
the sensitivity specificity on a statistical
cross-validation world.
So in other words, we pool the data where
every
element can be used, or every case can be
used, both as an element that we learn from
and as an element that
we can assess the predictive power of these
algorithms.
So it is very interesting.
It's a very rapidly evolving field.
Obviously, there'll be mistakes.
Let me remind you of the
Google Flu Trends fluke, things are not going--
some things are not going to work well, some
things will work well.
And I know I'm out of time, so I'll stop here,
but any other questions or quick ideas, Jack
?
I think we've run out of time.
But I do hope that our audience will feel
free to find Dr. Dinov of the University of
Michigan and shoot him an email, should you
have any additional questions for him.
I'm sure that he'd be
delighted to answer them.
But I hope you'll also join me in thanking
Dr. Dinov for his presentation on big data
brain
science and health analytics for our BD2K
guide to the fundamentals of data science.
Thank you so much Ivo, it was an absolute
pleasure.
And I want to thank our audience for taking
the time today to
join us.
I want to wish everybody a happy holidays
and do watch for-- this will be our last data
science seminar for
2017, but start watching for a new collection
of these to begin shortly after the new year.
Once again, thank you,
everybody.
Happy holidays and my best to you and yours
for the remainder of the year.
Anyway, thanks so much
again.